pues Buen día para ustedes de un solo
pueblo muy lluvioso amanece el día de
hoy pero amanece además con nuevo
presidente y con nuevos gobernadores
Lula da Silva ha dicho después es de 12
años que regresa al poder una de sus
frases más emblemáticas de anoche fue
intentaron enterarme vivo y aquí estoy
para gobernar de nuevo el país ha dicho
Además de que uno de sus principales e
iniciales retos será combatir el hambre
en un país donde cada vez se ven más
habitantes de calle y más mendicidad
empeorados Pues por el contexto de la
pandemia dijo también que Brasil ha
vuelto y que se enfocará en primera
línea también en los compromisos para el
combate del cambio climático y de la
crisis climática como usted lo dijo muy
bien Es 50,9% para el Lula bolsonaro
49,1% un margen es sumamente estrecho
pero fue más que suficiente para sus
electores que celebraron hasta la
madrugada en la avenida paulista
nosotros estuvimos allí
una Avenida paulista absolutamente
eufórica absolutamente alegre no se
podía mover la gente el propio Lula da
Silva casi no puede llegar hasta la
paulista para esta prometida celebración
por las mareas y mareas de lulistas que
inundaron las calles y bueno un dato
para ustedes de Raúl eh Lula da Silva
nunca ha ganado en primera vuelta esta
no fue la excepción y además se cumplió
una de las predicciones tradicionales de
los brasileños Y es que el que gana en
Financiera dice gana en el resto del
país y efectivamente así fue bueno se
cumplieron entonces las predicciones y
también la estadística Ángela ese era el
lado de Lula digamos evidentemente el
ambiente de festividad de sus seguidores
pero nos vamos al otro lado del Perdedor
Que se sabe del actual presidente Yahir
bolsonaro Y que se dice en el país ante
su silencio no
pues mire la verdad es que es al menos
inquietante que bolsonaron no se haya
pronunciado todavía tradicionalmente El
que pierde hace una llamada al ganador
lo dijo Lula noche en la paulista un
presidente en Brasil y en cualquier
parte del mundo normalmente al perder
debería Llamar a conceder su derrota sin
embargo esto no ha pasado ya pasaron más
de 12 horas desde que el Tribunal
Superior electoral de Brasil concedió a
la victoria lulada Silva y bolsonaro aún
no se pronuncia lo que se sabe es que el
ayer vio una parte del conteo desde una
residencia cercana a plan alto en
Brasilia después se desplazó hasta
Brasilia allí terminó de ver las
elecciones y cuando finalizaron
simplemente se fue a dormir sin dar
declaraciones eso fue lo que se dijo
digamos de manera oficial para el día de
hoy no tiene agenda oficial tampoco el
presidente Así que no esperamos verlo
Próximamente en declaraciones por otros
temas y bueno en su discurso de
celebración de anoche Lula da Silva
habló poca digamos faltando un poco de
15 minutos para la medianoche y lo que
dijo es hasta este momento no he
recibido ninguna llamada de bolsonaro no
sé si la voy a recibir no sé si él va a
aceptar el resultado de las elecciones
pero aquí pues también aceptó Lula da
Silva que hay mucha gente que quedó con
rabia después de la elección de ayer y
pues producto de la gran polarización
que vive el país y pues aceptó que tiene
que hacer un gran trabajo para bajar los
humos de calmar los ánimos Aunque mucho
de eso Raúl francamente dependerá de lo
que diga Jair bolsonaro nosotros
seguimos esperando conocer algún
comunicado oficial